hello there you're watching the press
preview first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what is making the headlines with
the consultant editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce and the associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire lovely
to see you guys i will be speaking to
them in a moment see you jay they'll be
with us all the way through until
midnight nearly so let's see what is on
the front of some of those papers and
referencing the prime minister's
presence at the climate summit the metro
calls his refusal to apologize amid
allegations of tory sleaze a bit of a
cop-out the daily telegraph leads with
the duchess of sussex reportedly
apologizing for unintentionally not
mentioning her aids contact with authors
that is also the lead on the front of
the daily express
hundreds of companies set up during the
government's furlough scheme are now
under investigation for potential fraud
according to the times
the financial times has a story
concerning the us consumer price index
which the paper says is growing at its
fastest rate for 30 years
and on a lighter note the daily star
says the uk is becoming a nation of
cocktail drinkers
we'll be getting their favorite
cocktails by the end of the show i'm
sure we're joined tonight by andrew
pearce and kevin mcguire lovely to see
both of you guys um to cocktails later
but first of all uh to to what's
happening in parliament um and the prime
minister's journey up to glasgow at the
metro
have gone with a bit of a cop out uh and
and the guardian two have also targeted
uh jeffrey cox um andrew um the prime
minister doesn't think he's got anything
to to apologize about does he
well the prime minister just flatly
refuses to apologize um i think it would
be just easier if he'd uh gone to the
debate which was held him on monday in
the commons instead of um skulking
around in a hospital in northumberland
he could have flown back he could have
he could easily have been there uh
instead he sent the uh
chance of the justice language steve
barkley in to bat for him i think steve
barkley did very well he talked about
mistakes the government had made but
earlier you know um the education
secretary nadine sahari at the weekend
said he used the word sorry
so it seems to be a hard word for the
prime minister to utter the fact is the
whole shambles over
owen patterson the former cabinet
minister and the
standards committee report which said he
should be suspended from the commons for
30 days was incredibly badly handled by
boris johnson and the government uh
forcing mps to vote something they
didn't want he should have apologized
over that in my view and um and he but
he has said without naming jeffrey cox
that mps who break the rules should be
punished and i suspect jeffrey cox sir
jeffrey of course mustn't um do the old
do the old man down the former attorney
general is in hot water not just because
how much money he's been making and the
fact he's missed commons votes
while he's been
lining his pocket but because he clearly
used his house of commons office doing
legal work for which he was being paid a
king's ransom that's clint simply
against the rules whatever he says in
his statement today uh and why didn't he
allow anyone to question him about this
thing he would put a statement on his
website we still don't know where he is
jane is he still in the british virgin
islands earning even more money as a
lawyer or is he on holiday but he
doesn't appear to be at home and we're
told he's abroad
kevin i mean obviously it is fairly easy
for the labour party to throw stones at
the government on this one but is it not
important that mps have got experience
of life outside of politics we don't
want all of our politicians to be career
politicians do we
jane it's not just labor throwing stones
at the at the government it's all the
other political parties liberal
democrats greens blind comradery sn np
but it's also a lot of tory mps are
throwing stones at their own leadership
in their own party over the handling of
this because it's a it's a disaster it's
a it's made in downing street because
owen patterson could have
taken his punishment had his 30-day
suspension and it would have been over
instead the prime minister was engulfed
in a crisis because he tried to change
the rules to save one of his
own and then got this ferocious public
uh backlash now you want mps to have
experience of life absolutely but does
that mean
that a significant minority of them that
experiences earning uh rather large
fortunes fortunate they probably
wouldn't get if they were out in the
public on the jobs market in the labor
market and they weren't mps is that what
you really want don't they then begin to
lose touch if you want more mps in in
touch with them the public we probably
want more taxi drivers bus drivers
industrial workers carers that's
probably who we want rather than people
who can go into parliament and then use
their position and contacts to get juicy
juicy contracts
the sons and daughters of a lot of those
those people in in in politics don't we
at the moment but but as you say not not
people who are doing it as an extra job
andrew the guardian um
and the times two um have gone with
jeffrey cox but um in terms of the sums
the guardian is saying he made six
million pounds from his second job while
he's been an uh an mp i mean that's an
astonishing sum isn't it
yeah look he's clearly a brilliant
lawyer
and um clearly a lot better than
kierstarma who who was also earning
money as an mp as a lawyer working
outside he made it just over a hundred
thousand i think jeffrey cox in 10 15
years has made six million pounds when
does he find the time to be an mp uh and
why does he bother being an mp because
it's frankly small change 81 000 pounds
a year it is staggering he's clearly got
he will no doubt i think go down in
history as the most well-paid mp outside
of the commons in history i would think
um i don't think even um theresa theresa
may is doing pretty well actually she's
up to 1.6 million and she's only been
out of number 10 for a few years but
she's not doing that um as a lawyer in
in lengthy court cases she's making
speeches on the international lecture
circuit and bizarrely people want to pay
a lot of money to hear her speak i
wouldn't but a lot of politics i mean we
know that tony blair has also made a lot
of money since he's you know left it's
it's not an unusual thing for for for a
leader to make money but it is perhaps
unusual to make six million quid while
you're actually in the job isn't it
kevin
yeah well if you're if you're making six
million pounds as a lawyer you've got to
think isn't that his main job and being
an mp is his second job he's part-time
job he's he's hobby uh
is he a brilliant lawyer or is he just a
very high charging lucrative lawyer
because of the jobs he'll take
prepared to go off to the the british
virgin islands a pretty squalid tax
haven in the in the caribbean and work
there and then do do with the jobs
how much could an mp earn how much it's
a debate we're going to have to have now
because of
jeffrey cox
because if rules come in it may be well
you can apply your trade you can't you
can't do something you you wouldn't have
normally had any expertise and you
already wanted because you're an mp
you're going to think well he's buying
his trade but that amount of money
people in uh in torridge and west
steffen must think uh he's just got a
lifestyle that has no connection to most
of them and this this is where there is
a there's a problem on that it will
stick in people's throats particularly
when taxes are going up prices are going
up and living stances are going to be
squeezed that's why sleaze matters if
the economy was absolutely booming
people might think less of it but when
they can see they're going to be told to
tighten their belts by the the
chancellor they're going to resent some
uh mps and they are it's only some tory
mps in particular uh seem to be living
the life of riley and earning a fortune
another story you know the irony is yeah
there's there's an irony here as well
because i've been looking at jeffrey cox
majority and his constituency down there
in devon it's been going up at every
election and at the last election he got
over 60 percent of the vote so um
maybe he's just uh yeah he's hardly ever
there because he seems to be spending so
much time out of the country working but
he's got it's a pretty solid safe seat
although i have to say if in any way he
was forced out over any of this the tory
party would not want a by-election to be
fought on the issue of sleeves but i
don't think it will come to that i
suspect what we're gonna hear from sir
jeffrey cox at some point is you know oh
boy i think i've decided to stand down
at the next election and spend more time
with my legal briefs
we shall see
let's move on
you see how it will play out i know we
could talk about this online we can talk
about it more about after 11 but another
story that is um
going to be raising uh some red faces in
the house of commons it's on the front
of the times it's also in the tele on
the front of the telegraph as well uh
and this is about some mps who went out
to gibraltar um and
kevin they got slightly over refreshed
on the journey
yeah a rather nice way of putting it the
allegation is three of the 15 mps on a
trip one labour a female woman who's not
named two snp men who are named although
it's disputed by the snp are said as you
say to have been over refreshed and
become difficult the female labor mp is
said to have been so incapacitated she
actually couldn't go meet the troops
when she was due to
the two snp uh mps are alleged to have
been difficult with uh customs and
testing uh staff
it does not reflect well on mps ben
wallace the defense secretary he said to
be writing to the parties to complain
that because we haven't got the full
versions of it but i'm sure the times
and the telegraph will have had their
lawyers all over those stories before
they uh before they run them they're
written pretty carefully but it doesn't
sound as if it was the the finest days
for those three yeah three mps
the the
one
i think the telegraph has actually named
the uh woman labour mp i'm not going to
do that because um uh the times haven't
but apparently she was so um shall we
say well refreshed as uh jane put it she
had to be escorted off the plane in a
wheelchair because she was incapable of
walking the journey into the um into the
immigration so um i imagine she's had a
hell of a hangover and she was
apparently ordered by the labour whips
to return home sooner from gibraltar and
i imagine she's now going to have a
difficult time but with the party
managers
jake jane i have no friends i have no
information on this story but i know if
if we were doing at the mirror we would
be checking her medical records and
whether she was on some sort of
medication and it could have been
something else or reaction to a drink i
just i just say that in the interest of
fairness but i don't i don't i don't
have any information i think that's fair
enough uh um a story we didn't quite get
to in part one and this is about the cop
conference um it looks like the us and
china have reached a tentative deal um
andrew i mean is is this really progress
yeah it is because look they are the two
biggest polluters in the world china
didn't send the president didn't go to
the summit he hasn't left china since
kobe struck perhaps he's feeling too
guilty in case it was his wretched
laboratories which spread the pandemic
in the first place but um the chinese
there was a press there's going to be a
press conference tomorrow they are
there's going to be some joint
announcement on reducing methane which
is a very important um part of the
battle against climate change so that's
a big significant step um and um any and
i think we're going to see in the last
48 hours of code over the last 24 hours
jane frantic behind the scenes arm
twisting and negotiating because the
government has produced a seven page
draft which has got quite a lot of deep
but got a lot of woolly statements but
very little specifics so if there's a
breakthrough with china and america
that's pretty big
and kevin let's move on to the story
about um megan and the telegraph and
it's also a couple of the others as well
um she has now admitted that she misled
the court when when this is to do with
uh the libel action and to do with
whether or not she authorized a
biography she she she's now admitted
that she forgot that she did it actually
tell some people they could speak to
their biographer
yeah she's she says she inadvertently
misled the court so there's unlikely to
be
any perjury case or anything like that
because she says it was a mistake but
all along she's maintained she's been
defending her privacy but this admission
in and it's supported by emails and the
testimony of her former press secretary
who discussed with her and actually had
a briefing note was going to speak to
two people for a couple of hours who
wrote a book uh very favorable to meghan
markle and harry windsor finding freedom
and also when she was writing that
letter to her father she thought it
might be leaked so it was written in a
way that would make her appear good if
it was leaked calling her her father
daddy because it would pull at
heartstrings
it's embarrassing for her
in a legal case it's embarrassing when
she and her husband have been talking
about the need to be totally accurate uh
and avoid disinformation in the
the us it's just another twist and an
incredible uh soap opera of how that
couple we're going to be the new face
and the future of the royal family were
incredibly popular got anything
really
a very
gushing press in the uk and then all of
a sudden turned sour as she was pushing
up against the royals
allegations of treating staff badly and
then you get into this round where some
people say she's all a victim of um
sexism reaction and racism and they get
other people saying well she was just a
ruthless social climber on the make all
the way well if in fact she could be a
victim of racism and uh and snobbery and
at the same time also be a ruthless uh
social climber and not particularly nice
very briefly andrew it's not been a
great year for the queen has it
no no and um she'll want this court case
resolved as quickly as possible but
what's quite interesting about the first
the press secretary to got the duchess
of sussex who um in fact had a two-hour
meeting with the authors of that book
and she'd forgotten about it apparently
and she'd forgotten about the emails
which he produced he actually now works
for william and kate he runs their
charitable foundation so that is going
to be quite uncomfortable it is right
because we've got 45 seconds left and
this daily star is leading with right
now a nation of cocktail drinkers uh two
pints of mojito and a packet of crisp
clays that says um you'd be going some
if you had two pints of meat what would
be your favorite cocktail kevin
uh i don't know i'll have a mojito just
because it's in that headline you're
gonna say a lager top
my cocktail will be anything with gin in
it i think i'll probably go mojito this
would be a good party